The argument is simple. Why have an eagle as your national bird? The eagle is a bird of bad moral character. He does not get his living honestly. He sits on the tree branch, watches other birds swoop down for fish. Once they grab the fish, the eagle chases them, steals the fish. Also, he's a coward. At least that is the argument that Benjamin Franklin lays out in a letter dated January 26, 1784.
这个论点很简单。为什么要把鹰作为国鸟呢？鹰是一种道德品质败坏的鸟。它不诚实地谋生。它坐在树枝上，看着其他鸟俯冲下去抓鱼。一旦那些鸟抓到了鱼，鹰就会去追赶它们，把鱼抢走。而且，它还是个懦夫。至少这就是本杰明·富兰克林在1784年1月26日的一封信中所提出的论点。
"It would be far better if the symbol of the new United States of America were a turkey," Franklin writes. Quote, "The turkey is, in comparison, a much more respectable, and withal a true, original native of America. Eagles have been found in all countries, but turkey was peculiar to ours. He is besides, though a little vain and silly, a bird of courage and would not hesitate to attack a grenadier of British guards who should presume to invade his farm yard with a red coat on."
“如果美利坚合众国的新象征是一只火鸡，那会好得多，”富兰克林写道。引用如下：“相比之下，火鸡是一种更令人尊敬的，而且是美国真正、原生的物种。鹰在所有国家都能找到，但火鸡是我们国家特有的。此外，虽然火鸡有点虚荣和愚蠢，但它是一种勇敢的鸟，如果有英国卫队的掷弹兵敢戴着红外套侵犯它的农场，它会毫不犹豫地发起攻击。”
A modern American reads this and thinks, bird of courage?
一个现代美国人读到这里会想，勇敢的鸟？
Well the wild turkey of the 18th century was very different from the butterball turkey of Thanksgiving day dinner.
嗯，18世纪的野生火鸡与感恩节晚餐上的肥火鸡非常不同。
That's Jack Hitt. He is one of contributing editors here at This American Life . He has written about the Benjamin Franklin papers in The New York Times. He writes about history, biology and pretty much anything else he wants to in various national magazines. And he offered to explain this turkey mystery.
那是杰克·希特。他是《美国生活》节目的特约编辑之一。他曾在《纽约时报》撰写过关于本杰明·富兰克林文件的文章。他为各种全国性杂志撰写关于历史、生物学以及他想写的几乎任何内容。他主动提出要解释这个火鸡之谜。
If you look at the label of a Wild Turkey bottle, you're probably closer to Ben Franklin's turkey than the one in the grocery store. It's all leg. It's fast. It's speedy. It's an athletic bird. It has almost no breast whatsoever. And if you've hunted them, they're incredibly quick and smart, whereas over the centuries, the turkey was eventually bred into this enormous walking piece of breast meat.
如果你看一眼“野火鸡”（Wild Turkey）酒瓶上的标签，你可能会发现它比杂货店里的火鸡更接近本·富兰克林的火鸡。它全是腿。它很快。它很敏捷。它是一种运动型的鸟。它几乎完全没有胸肉。如果你猎过它们，你会发现它们极其敏捷聪明，而几个世纪以来，火鸡最终被培育成这种巨大的、行走的胸肉块。
The turkey itself is so front-heavy-- I think in some cases, they even have trouble walking towards the end.
火鸡本身重心太靠前——我想在某些情况下，它们到最后甚至连走路都有困难。
You're saying that we as a nation have altered the turkey from a smart, fast cunning animal into a stupid, heavy one.
你是说，作为一个国家，我们已经把火鸡从一种聪明、快速、狡猾的动物变成了一种愚蠢、笨重的动物。
What we've done really is hybridize it to the point where it's just basically a living dinner waiting to get on the table. There's really nothing about the turkey from its birth until its death that is about anything except being a meal.
我们真正做的是将它杂交到一种地步，基本上它就只是等待被端上餐桌的活生生的晚餐。从出生到死亡，火鸡除了成为食物之外，几乎没有任何意义。
And is the thing about poultry, that probably more than any other animal, we've turned birds, chicken, turkey, into what we want them to be. Which means that chickens and turkeys, more than other animals, are a mirror of ourselves, of our desires, of our needs. When we tell stories about poultry, we're telling stories about ourselves. And given this, and given the history of the turkey in America, maybe Benjamin Franklin was right. Maybe it should be the symbol of our nation.
关于家禽的问题在于，比起任何其他动物，我们可能更多地把鸟类——鸡、火鸡——变成了我们想要它们成为的样子。这意味着鸡和火鸡比其他动物更能反映我们自己，反映我们的欲望，我们的需求。当我们讲述关于家禽的故事时，我们其实是在讲述我们自己的故事。鉴于此，并考虑到火鸡在美国的历史，也许本杰明·富兰克林是对的。也许它应该成为我们国家的象征。
In a way it begs the metaphor. I mean he's saying that this should be the symbol of our country. And I wonder if maybe it should, depending on what you think of the United States of America.
在某种程度上，这引出了一个隐喻。我的意思是，他说这应该成为我们国家的象征。我想知道，根据你对美利坚合众国的看法，也许它确实应该如此。
You're saying that if we had chosen it 200 years ago, it would have neatly tracked our national growth. Are you saying that now, we're more like the contemporary turkey than we were like Ben Franklin's turkey?
你是说，如果我们200年前选择了它，它会很好地追踪我们国家的发展轨迹。你是说现在我们更像当代火鸡，而不是本·富兰克林的火鸡？
I guess I am saying that.
我想我是这么说的。
That we're fat and out of shape and lazy and somewhat retarded?
我们肥胖、身材走样、懒惰，而且有点迟钝？
I mean I admit, it's a little post-Vietnam syndrome. I'm going to suggest this. A little unfashionably, post-Vietnam syndrome.
我承认，这有点“后越战综合症”。我想提出这一点。有点不合时宜地，后越战综合症。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International. It is This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. And we, all of us, we stand at this moment poised between Thanksgiving and Christmas. We are in the weeks during the year when Americans consume more poultry than at any other time, which means it's time for This American Life's annual Poultry Slam. Stories about chickens, turkeys, ducks, fowl all kinds, and their mysterious hold over us.
好了，来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台。这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们，我们所有人都正处于感恩节和圣诞节之间。我们处于一年中美国人消费家禽最多的几周，这意味着是时候进行《美国生活》一年一度的“家禽狂欢”了。关于鸡、火鸡、鸭子、各种禽类以及它们对我们那种神秘控制力的故事。
Now Jack, although you're happily, and at our bidding, discussing Ben Franklin and turkeys, that is not the reason why you're here with us today, is it?
那么杰克，虽然你很高兴并且应我们的要求讨论本·富兰克林和火鸡，但这并不是你今天来这儿的原因，对吧？
No, actually I'm here for another poultry-related subject.
不，其实我是为了另一个与家禽有关的主题而来的。
Let me just ask you to just give us a little hint. Just drop a phrase or two.
让我请你给我们一点暗示。随便说一两个词。
Two words Ira, Chicken Little.
两个词，艾拉，“小鸡快跑”（Chicken Little）。
Chicken Little. Adults all over America are turning off their radios. You think chicken little is that much of a draw?
小鸡快跑。全美国的成年人都在关掉收音机。你觉得小鸡快跑有那么大的吸引力吗？
Let me try that again. Two words Ira. Avian supernumeraries.
让我再试一次。两个词，艾拉。禽类龙套（Avian supernumeraries）。
Well, Act One of our program today, Chicken Diva, in which we hear the story of yes, avian supernumeraries.
好的，我们今天节目的第一幕，“鸡剧名伶”（Chicken Diva），在这一幕中，我们将听到关于——是的，禽类龙套的故事。
Act Two, Headless Chicken in Topless Bar. Actually, there is no topless bar in that act. We just like the sound of that. But there is a headless chicken and a question. What does the headless chicken say about us?
第二幕，“无头鸡在无上装酒吧”。事实上，那一幕里没有无上装酒吧。我们只是喜欢那个名字听起来的感觉。但确实有一只无头鸡和一个问题。这只无头鸡说明了我们什么？
Act Three, Duck Warrior. Michael Lewis explains the natural way to hunt duck and his family's way.
第三幕，“鸭子战士”。迈克尔·刘易斯解释了狩猎鸭子的自然方式和他家族的方式。
Act Four, Trying to Respect the Chicken, the story of one woman's quest to give chicken the honor and dignity they are rarely accorded, even though the chickens resist her efforts. Stay with us.
第四幕，“试图尊重那只鸡”，讲述了一位女性试图给予鸡它们很少得到的荣誉和尊严的故事，尽管鸡们抵制她的努力。请留下来。
Act One, Chicken Diva. Chickens are what we make of them. For further evidence of this, we have this story from our contributing editor, Jack Hitt.
第一幕，鸡剧名伶。鸡是我们塑造出的样子。为了进一步证明这一点，我们有来自我们的特约编辑杰克·希特的这个故事。
Oddly enough, it wasn't Susan who was obsessed with chickens. It was Kenny, a pal who worked backstage at the 92 Street Y in New York. His house was filled with chicken cups, chicken masks, porcelain chickens. He got the whole staff onto chickens, including Susan. For a time there in the '80's, poultry-related jokes and references became the fast way to get a laugh at the Y. I guess most of us are condemned to see nothing more than the easy comedy of chickens, but Susan Vitucci saw something else, their potential greatness, their hidden beauty, their grandeur.
奇怪的是，痴迷于鸡的不是苏珊。是肯尼，一个在纽约92街Y中心做后台工作的朋友。他的房子里到处是鸡形杯子、鸡面具、陶瓷鸡。他让整个员工团队都迷上了鸡，包括苏珊。在那段80年代的时光里，与家禽有关的笑话和引用成了在Y中心博取笑声的捷径。我想我们大多数人注定只能看到鸡身上那种简单的滑稽，但苏珊·维图奇看到了别的东西，它们的潜在伟大、隐藏的美丽、它们的庄严。
One day, she glued together some finger puppets for a 10-minute rendition of the Chicken Little story for her nephew. That was 14 years ago. Today, it is a full-length opera, enjoyed by a cult following whenever it goes up in a workshop or cafe or small theater. It's still performed with finger puppets, but now it has a complete score written by a noted composer, Henry Krieger, who did Dreamgirls, and this season has a hit on Broadway, a musical called Side Show. The Chicken Little opera he wrote with Susan Vitucci is called Love's Fowl . Needless to say, that's F-O-W-L.
有一天，她把一些手指玩偶粘在一起，为她的侄子表演了10分钟的《小鸡快跑》故事。那是14年前的事了。今天，它是一部完整的歌剧，每当它在工作坊、咖啡馆或小剧院上演时，都会受到狂热粉丝的喜爱。它仍然是用手指玩偶表演的，但现在有了由著名作曲家亨利·克里格创作的完整配乐，他曾创作过《追梦女孩》，并且本季在百老汇有一部热门音乐剧《边演边唱》。他和苏珊·维图奇创作的《小鸡快跑》歌剧名为《爱的禽鸟》（Love's Fowl）。不用说，拼写是F-O-W-L。
Well, we were going to start with the opening, [SPEAKING ITALIAN] We are the Clothespin Repertory Theater. And we have a special singing guest for you, which I don't know--
嗯，我们打算从序幕开始，[意大利语] 我们是晾衣夹剧团。我们为您准备了一位特别的演唱嘉宾，我不确定——
Susan and I are sitting at Henry's baby grand piano. Henry's guest is his Maltese terrier named Toby.
苏珊和我正坐在亨利的三角钢琴旁。亨利的嘉宾是他的马耳他梗犬，名叫托比。
Perhaps Toby would be kind enough to join me over here.
也许托比愿意赏光加入我这边。
Yeah, would she sit on your lap for this?
是啊，她会坐你腿上表演这个吗？
Yeah, let's see what we can do.
好的，看看我们能做些什么。
OK, listen carefully because once Toby gets going, he actually harmonizes with Henry and Susan.
好吧，仔细听，因为一旦托比进入状态，它真的会和亨利与苏珊进行和声。
[MUSIC - LOVE'S FOWL] [DOG BARKING]
[音乐 - 爱的禽鸟] [狗叫声]
You may have noticed that this libretto is an Italian, just like a real opera.
你可能已经注意到这个剧本是意大利语的，就像真正的歌剧一样。
Before, it was just a bunch of puppets and a box, with a good idea. And then suddenly, since it went into Italian, it became something bigger than what it had been. And it's because when it's in English, we all know it, and it's really not that interesting. It's like, yeah, yeah, yeah. As soon as it's in Italian, it gives us enough distance that we can come in. It makes us-- it's like the lover who doesn't want you. You don't want anybody more than you want the one who doesn't want you. Right? And it's sort of the same thing.
以前，它只是一堆玩偶和一个盒子，加上一个好点子。然后突然间，因为它变成了意大利语，它就变得比以前更宏大了。这是因为当它是英语时，我们都知道它，这其实并不有趣。就像，是啊，是啊，是啊。一旦它变成了意大利语，它就给了我们足够的距离感，让我们能走进去。它让我们——就像那个不想要你的爱人。你想要某个人，胜过想要那个不想要你的人。对吧？这基本上是同一回事。
[MUSIC - LOVE'S FOWL]
[音乐 - 爱的禽鸟]
You may recall that when you last heard of Little, back in kindergarten, she was just an average, barn door fowl who had an acorn drop on our head, which she mistakenly understood to be the sky falling. Her alarms excited her friends, Goosey Loosey, Turkey Lurkey, and Ducky Lucky. And they join her for a journey to the King to tell him the important news. On the way, they meet up with Sly Fox. Little's pals eagerly accept his invitation for dinner, literally as it turns out. Fortunately for Little, hunger is not enough to distract her from her mission, and she treks on.
你可能还记得，当你上次在幼儿园听到“小鸡”的故事时，她只是一只普通的谷仓家禽，头上掉了一颗橡子，她误以为是天要塌下来了。她的惊慌感染了她的朋友们，鹅宝宝、火鸡拉基和鸭子卢基。他们和她一起踏上了去告诉国王这个重要消息的旅程。路上，他们遇到了狡猾的狐狸。狐狸盛情邀请这几个伙伴去吃晚饭，结果事实证明，他们成了晚饭。幸运的是，饥饿并没有让小鸡从她的使命中分心，她继续前行。
When she meets the King, he tells her that the sky is not falling. It's just an acorn. So the enlightened Chicken Little returns to her coop, and that's where the story ends. Like Goldilocks and so many children's fables, the actual meaning of the story is obscure. What are we to take away from Little's experience? I like to think that Little is rewarded with life precisely because she went off on this Quixotic mission, totally in the grip of a wrong idea. By clinging to that belief, however crazy, she managed to free herself from the ugly Darwinian world of the barnyard and of its mandate, eat or be eaten.
当她见到国王时，国王告诉她天没有塌。那只是一颗橡子。于是，开悟的小鸡回到了她的鸡窝，故事到此结束。像《金发姑娘》和许多儿童寓言一样，这个故事的真正含义是模糊的。我们从小鸡的经历中得到了什么？我愿意认为，小鸡之所以能活下来，恰恰是因为她踏上了这场堂吉诃德式的使命，完全被一个错误的想法所俘获。通过坚持那个信念，无论它有多疯狂，她成功地把自己从谷仓院子里那个丑陋的达尔文主义世界，以及它那“弱肉强食”的法则中解放了出来。
[MUSIC - LOVE'S FOWL]
[音乐 - 爱的禽鸟]
The children's fable barely figures into the story. It's just one small episode in the life of Chicken Little, now known as La Pulcina Piccola. After the acorn incident, she goes on to become an internationally renowned figure in almost every field imaginable, a diva of politics, academe, theater, art, derring-do.
这则儿童寓言在这个故事中几乎没占什么篇幅。它只是小鸡一生中的一个小插曲，她现在被称为“小鸡小姐”（La Pulcina Piccola）。在橡子事件之后，她继续成为几乎所有可想象领域内国际知名的名流，一位政治、学术、戏剧、艺术和冒险领域的歌剧名伶。
Like Venus, she arrives from some other world, transported on a scallop shell. But the triumphs of her life begin after a youthful love affair with a fighting cock ends bitterly. And she consoles herself, as we all do at some point in our lives, by plunging into Shakespeare. She becomes an overnight sensation as an actress, celebrated all over the world for one role. Juliet? Cleopatra? Ophelia?
像维纳斯一样，她从另一个世界降临，乘坐扇贝壳运输而来。但她一生的胜利始于一段与一只斗鸡的年轻恋情苦涩地结束后。她像我们生活中某个时刻都会做的那样，沉浸在莎士比亚作品中来慰藉自己。她一夜成名，成为了一名女演员，因扮演一个角色而享誉全球。朱丽叶？克利奥帕特拉？奥菲利亚？
The company then performs an excerpt, a recreation of her signature role, which is Richard III. [LAUGHTER] Well, I mean Sarah Bernhardt did Hamlet.
公司随后表演了一个片段，重现了她的招牌角色，也就是理查三世。[笑声] 嗯，我的意思是萨拉·伯恩哈特也演过哈姆雷特。
Well, there's a great tradition of women playing the men's roles in Shakespeare, but I think Richard III is one of the more rare roles to be played by a woman.
嗯，女性在莎士比亚剧中扮演男性角色有着伟大的传统，但我认为理查三世是女性扮演的比较罕见的角色之一。
Well, that's how adventuresome an actress this chicken was.
嗯，这就是这只鸡作为演员有多么大胆。
I can assure you, there's nothing like watching a four-inch tall finger puppet crying out, "A horse, a horse, my kingdom for a horse" in Italian. Not to mention that that puppet is a chicken, surrounded by a whole supporting cast of poultry and other avian supernumeraries. Susan says that, artistically, there's something special about chickens.
我可以向你保证，没有什么比看着一个四英寸高的手指玩偶用意大利语大喊“一匹马，一匹马，我的王国换一匹马”更奇妙的了。更不用说那个玩偶是一只鸡，周围是一群家禽和其他禽类龙套演员。苏珊说，从艺术上讲，鸡身上确实有些特别之处。
They're a clean slate in a way. I mean they're actually very dirty birds. But you can put anything on them. You can project anything to them because it's not like they have, to me at least, a very strong personality. I have a cat. I live with this cat. I know he has a very strong personality. He's a real creature. I mean he has a persona. Whereas the chickens are a group, and they have a personality as a group, but not individually.
它们在某种程度上是一张白纸。我的意思是，它们实际上是非常脏的鸟。但你可以把任何东西投射到它们身上。你可以把任何东西投射给它们，因为在我看来，它们不像是有非常强烈的个性。我有一只猫。我和这只猫住在一起。我知道他有非常强烈的个性。他是一个真正的生物。我的意思是，他有一个人格。而鸡是一个群体，它们作为一个整体有个性，但个体之间没有。
Except for La Pulcina. In the opera, she moves into the field of archaeology, masters it, needless to say, and makes a great discovery, the last tomb of [? Gallopatra. ?] But not before she sails the seven seas, is ship wrecked, gets rescued, but it's by pirates, and then she meets the pirate king.
除了“小鸡小姐”。在歌剧里，她进入了考古学领域，精通了它，不用说，她还做出了重大发现，[加洛帕特拉]的最后陵墓。但在那之前，她航行在七大洋，遭遇海难，被救出，但救她的是海盗，然后她遇见了海盗王。
As soon as he meets her, he falls in love with because of her sweet spirit. Because she comes in, and she says, "Here you see a little chicken who, although I'm dripping wet, I'm proud and yellow."
当他遇见她时，他立刻爱上了她，因为她那甜美的灵魂。因为她走进来，她说：“在这里你看到的是一只小鸡，虽然我全身湿透，但我骄傲且金黄。”
Let me repeat that lyric for you in a purer translation. "Although I stand before you, a chicken who is dripping wet, I am proud, and I am yellow." OK, back to Susan.
让我为你用更纯粹的翻译重复一遍那句歌词。“虽然我站在你面前，是一只全身湿透的小鸡，但我很骄傲，我是金黄的。”好的，回到苏珊身上。
"And although I've loved and I have lost, I have learned to follow the call of adventure. So let's sail on."
“虽然我爱过也失去过，但我已经学会了追随冒险的呼唤。所以，让我们起航吧。”
[MUSIC - LOVE'S FOWL]
[音乐 - 爱的禽鸟]
Keep in mind that all of the action, like everything that occurs in every Susan Vitucci production, ever since the first one for her nephew and continuing to this day, occurs among characters created by sticking a small, painted Styrofoam ball onto to a larger painted Styrofoam ball, poking on two map tacks for eyes, gluing on a tiny, felt beak, and then impaling the whole thing on top of one of those really old-fashioned clothespins that a '40's cartoon figure would clamp to his nose around a chunk of Limburger cheese.
请记住，所有的动作，就像苏珊·维图奇每一部作品中发生的每件事一样，从给侄子的第一部开始一直持续到今天，都发生在由这些角色构成的世界中：将一个小小的、涂色的泡沫球粘在一个较大的涂色泡沫球上，用两个地图图钉戳出眼睛，粘上一个小小的毛毡喙，然后把整个东西插在一根那种真正老式的晾衣夹顶端——就是那种40年代卡通人物会夹在鼻子上吃林堡干酪的那种。
[MUSIC - LOVE'S FOWL]
[音乐 - 爱的禽鸟]
And I could go on. She takes a cowboy lover on the American frontier while on the lecture tour. Then there's an affair with an Italian professor modeled on a real 15th century naturalist who wrote a treatise on chickens. There's always another adventure, even outside the opera. Susan has written, or as she puts it, translated La Pulcina Piccola's diaries, which detail the other adventures that happen in between those in the opera. There are 60 pages so far, excerpts of which have appeared in Clothelines, the official fan club newsletter of the opera. Its masthead lists every category of donor.
我还可以继续说下去。她在巡回演讲时在美国边疆找了一个牛仔情人。然后还有一段与一位意大利教授的恋情，该角色以一位写过关于鸡的论文的真实15世纪博物学家为原型。总是还有其他的冒险，甚至在歌剧之外。苏珊写了，或者正如她所说的，翻译了“小鸡小姐”的日记，详细记录了那些发生在歌剧情节之间的其他冒险。目前已有60页，其中的节选出现在了歌剧官方粉丝俱乐部通讯《衣夹线》（Clothelines）上。它的刊头列出了每一类捐助者。
Zealot, fanatic, worshiper, admirer. A zealot has to give $250, a fanatic $100. Do you have any zealots?
狂热者、热衷者、崇拜者、仰慕者。狂热者必须捐赠250美元，热衷者100美元。你有任何狂热者吗？
Oh yeah, in fact actually, you can just give however much you want and call yourself whatever you want. So that we have people called [SPEAKING ITALIAN], which mean fine-feathered friends. We have a couple of those. And we have lovers. We have a couple of lovers.
哦，是的，事实上，你可以捐出任何你想捐的金额，并自称为任何你想叫的名字。所以我们有被称为[意大利语]的人，意思是“毛色漂亮的伙伴”。我们有几个那样的人。还有恋人。我们有几个恋人。
I'm not joking when I tell you that the high end donation is $500. People take this campy finger puppet opera quite seriously. When I was talking to Henry Krieger, he recalled the night he first saw a bare bones production of it at The West Bank Cafe in New York. And it was Krieger who approached Vitucci begging to write music for it.
我说高端捐赠是500美元时没有开玩笑。人们非常认真地对待这部充满营地风格的手指玩偶歌剧。当我和亨利·克里格交谈时，他回忆起他第一次在纽约西岸咖啡馆看到这部剧的原始版本时的那个夜晚。正是克里格找到维图奇，恳求为它写音乐。
Love's Fowl has this strange effect on people. I didn't understand until Susan loaned me a videotape of one performance. To be honest, I thought I would be annoyed at the intentional irony and hokiness of the puppets. I only agreed to watch it because I thought I would need the material to put together some wacky piece about poultry for This American Life. But there I was with my three-year-old daughter, who loved the show, watching a plastic bird pantomime one of the simplest human moments, but also one of the most profound, the confession of a great love. In this case, with a cock robin.
《爱的禽鸟》对人们有一种奇怪的影响。我直到苏珊借给我一份演出的录像带才明白这一点。老实说，我原以为我会因为玩偶的刻意讽刺和老套而感到恼火。我答应看它只是因为我认为我需要这些素材来为《美国生活》拼凑一些关于家禽的古怪稿子。但后来我和我三岁的女儿一起——她很喜欢这个节目——看着一只塑料鸟模仿人类最简单的时刻之一，同时也是最深刻的时刻之一，那就是对一份伟大爱情的告白。在这种情况下，对象是一只知更鸟。
The song that she sings as she enters goes, "I am a chicken and ready for love. My heart is as fragile as the egg from which I was born. Treat me gently, and so will I treat you. Together from earthly love, we will reach for the divine." And then she sings, "I'm a chicken, and I can't fly without love. My heart, it is as strong as the egg from which I was born." And so forth. And so it is only with Cock Robin that she flies.
她出场时唱的歌是：“我是一只鸡，准备好了去爱。我的心像我出生的那颗蛋一样脆弱。温柔地对待我，我也会如此对待你。让我们一起从尘世的爱中，触碰神圣。”然后她唱道：“我是一只鸡，没有爱我无法飞翔。我的心，像我出生的那颗蛋一样坚强。”诸如此类。所以，只有和知更鸟在一起时，她才能飞翔。
[MUSIC - LOVE'S FOWL]
[音乐 - 爱的禽鸟]
And after they have agreed to fly together, and they are soaring in the air, Cock Robin is shot and killed, murdered by a jealous sparrow. I couldn't believe it, but I was getting choked up, especially when Cock Robin appeared on the stage, his Styrofoam body spray-painted black for the lament, his little Magic Marker eyes drawn as X's.
而在他们同意一起飞翔，翱翔于天际之后，知更鸟被射中身亡，被一只嫉妒的麻雀谋杀了。我不敢相信，但我哽咽了，尤其是当知更鸟出现在舞台上时，他那泡沫塑料的身体为了哀悼被喷成了黑色，他那小小的记号笔画出的眼睛变成了叉号。
I gathered my daughter in my arms and held on tight as I was helplessly drawn into an expression of the grief and suffering of this little, sad bird. In this era of slick special effects, there was something unexpectedly liberating in the marriage of this crude medium, painted styrofoam balls bobbing up and down behind a cardboard box, and the high melodramatic art of Italian opera. Picture it.
我把女儿搂在怀里紧紧抱着，我无助地被吸引到对这只可怜小鸟的悲伤和痛苦的表达中。在这个特效精良的时代，这种粗糙的媒介——在纸板箱后上下跳动的彩绘泡沫球，与意大利歌剧那种高度夸张的艺术结合在一起，有着某种出人意料的解放感。想象一下。
[MUSIC - LOVE'S FOWL]
[音乐 - 爱的禽鸟]
I want a subscription to that newsletter.
我想要那个通讯的订阅。
Are you going to do this? I mean are you going to be working with Pulcina Piccola, you think, for the rest of your life?
你打算这样做吗？我是说，你觉得你会和“小鸡小姐”一起工作余生吗？
It's possible, and I like working with her because I can create an entire world. And I think that's what's the charm of it for me. I get to go into a world that's inhabited by a very sweet spirit and play with the mechanics of the world. And because it's very small-- I could never have afforded to produce this show with people. But I could afford to do it with clothespins. So I can do as big a production as I want with clothespins. I can have stuff fly in and out and come in from traps. And I can have all kinds of fancy, flashy stuff that costs millions of dollars to do on Broadway. And it costs me $200 because I had to buy lots and lots and lots of Styrofoam and clothespins and stuff and all this and a new table maybe. And I get to do whatever I want.
这有可能，而且我喜欢和她一起工作，因为我可以创造一个完整的世界。我认为这就是它对我来说的魅力所在。我可以进入一个由非常甜美的灵魂居住的世界，玩转这个世界的机制。而且因为它非常小——我永远无法负担得起用真人来制作这个节目。但我可以用晾衣夹来制作。所以我可以用晾衣夹制作我想要的任何宏大的作品。我可以让东西飞进飞出，从暗门里钻出来。我可以拥有各种百老汇花数百万美元才能做到的华丽、闪亮的东西。而它只花我200美元，因为我必须购买很多很多的泡沫塑料和晾衣夹之类的东西，还有可能是一张新桌子。我可以做任何我想做的事。
[MUSIC - LOVE'S FOWL]
[音乐 - 爱的禽鸟]
Jack Hitt's a writer who lives in New Haven.
杰克·希特是一位居住在纽黑文的作家。
Act Two, Headless Chicken in Topless Bar. Lloyd grew up in rural Virginia. His parents were city people who moved to the farm, people who decided that they'd raise goats, pigs, about 100 chickens. They would slaughter the birds by chopping off their heads with an axe. Now, we're going to get a little explicit here, so just be warned.
第二幕，“无头鸡在无上装酒吧”。劳埃德在弗吉尼亚州的农村长大。他的父母是搬到农场的城市人，他们决定饲养山羊、猪和大约100只鸡。他们会用斧头砍掉鸡的头来宰杀它们。现在，我们要说得稍微露骨一点，所以请做好心理准备。
It's a little nerve wracking because as soon as you cut the head off, a second or two will elapse, and then chicken explodes and starts to spazz out. And sometimes, they'll just lie on the ground, jerking and moving, but other times, they'll actually run and hop. And it's quite a sight because they're headless. Blood is coming out of the top of their neck. And I mean if you have 30 of these to do, they're going to disperse over a pretty large area. And I can remember chasing them, and frequently they would do evasive maneuvers. When you would try to reach down and grab them, they would jump to one side. And it seemed almost as if they could tell that you were there, which they couldn't. They didn't have a head.
这有点让人心惊肉跳，因为一旦你砍下头，一两秒钟过去，鸡就会爆炸并开始抽搐。有时它们只会躺在地上，抽动和移动，但有时它们真的会跑跳起来。这景象相当壮观，因为它们没有头。血从脖子顶端流出来。我的意思是，如果你有30只鸡要处理，它们会散布在很大的范围内。我记得追赶它们，它们经常会做规避动作。当你弯下腰试图抓住它们时，它们会跳向一边。这看起来几乎就像它们能感觉到你在那里，而实际上它们感觉不到。它们没有头。
We tried a lot of different techniques to deal with this messy situation. And I can remember one time we decided we'd cut the head off, and we'd throw them into a 55 gallon drum. But that was a mess, and it was really noisy because they bang around. And you can only put so many in there, and the blood starts to collect. And so that was really-- that didn't work.
我们尝试了许多不同的方法来处理这种混乱的状况。我记得有一次我们决定砍掉鸡头后，把它们扔进一个55加仑的桶里。但那是一场灾难，而且非常吵，因为它们在里面乱撞。你只能放进去那么多，而且血开始积聚。所以这真的——那行不通。
I remember one time, my uncle, Louis, came, and he was helping us do this. And he had heard that if you break the chicken's neck, as opposed to cutting it off, that somehow circumvents this reaction. And they don't spazz out. So he felt that the way to do that would be to grab the chicken by the head and swing it around his head. And he picked one up and swung it around his head a few times. And sure enough, the animal was dead, and it didn't go into this reaction.
我记得有一次，我的叔叔路易斯来了，他在帮我们做这件事。他听说如果你折断鸡的脖子，而不是切断它，那以某种方式绕过了这种反应。它们就不会抽搐。所以他觉得这样做的方法是抓住鸡头，然后在他的头周围挥动它。他拿起一只鸡，在头周围挥了几圈。果不其然，动物死了，它没有产生那种反应。
And so he stepped back, and my father picked up a chicken and did the same thing. And as he's swinging it around, I looked over at Louis, and I noticed that there was this line of chicken [BLEEP] that was going across his glasses because the bird had gone to the bathroom while my dad was swinging it around. And so we didn't really try that anymore, and we went back to the fence method.
于是他向后退了一步，我父亲拿起一只鸡也做了同样的事。就在他挥舞它的时候，我看向路易斯，注意到他的眼镜上有一道鸡屎线，因为在我爸爸挥舞它的时候，那只鸟排泄了。所以我们之后就没再尝试那样做了，我们又回到了栅栏法。
If you spend enough time around chickens, and you are a halfway empathetic or observant person, I think it's inevitable that at certain times, in certain ways, the boundary between the human world and the chicken world will get blurred. That happened to Lloyd.
如果你在鸡群中待的时间足够长，而且是一个稍微有同情心或观察力的人，我认为在某些时候，以某些方式，人类世界和鸡世界之间的界限必然会变得模糊。那件事发生在劳埃德身上。
Chickens are very hierarchical, and the higher chickens-- well, the chickens want to get to the highest part of the roost. And so there'd be constant fighting to get to the top, chickens damaging each other, pecking each other. But there would always be one or two chickens that had very few feathers. And because they were always being picked on, henpecked, they were the bottom of the pecking order. And these chickens, I felt sorry for them because it looked very uncomfortable, and I didn't like to see them suffering.
鸡非常有等级观念，高级的鸡——嗯，鸡想到达栖木的最高点。所以为了到达顶端会发生不断的斗争，鸡互相伤害，互相啄。但总会有那么一两只鸡几乎没有羽毛。因为它们总是被欺负，“被母鸡啄”（henpecked），它们在啄食顺序中处于底层。对于这些鸡，我感到很抱歉，因为看起来非常不舒服，我不喜欢看到它们受苦。
But I also felt-- they evoked a bit of anger in me because they were always hanging out in the corner or under foot. And they didn't go out in the yard usually. They would just hang out inside the house. And frequently, I think they just brought out the bully in a 10-year-old boy.
但我也感到——它们在某种程度上激起了我的愤怒，因为它们总是躲在角落里或脚下。它们通常不去院子里。它们只是躲在屋子里。而且我觉得，它们经常引出了一个10岁男孩身上的恶霸心理。
I had some anger that I would-- and I'm ashamed to admit, these henpecked animals would bring it out in me. And I would kick them them away if they were under foot and stuff like that. It was a mixture of feeling sorry for them and feeling derision.
我有一些愤怒，我会——我羞于承认，这些被欺负的动物会引出我的愤怒。如果它们在脚下，我会踢开它们之类的。那是歉意和嘲讽的混合体。
One way to look at the world is this. There's a life continuum. One one side, at the extreme end, you have plants and insects and stuff that most of us feel no remorse about killing or mistreating. On the other side of the continuum, at the other extreme, you have dogs and cats and baby seals and human beings, animals we do not feel free to just kill or eat or be cruel to. And the question is, where are chickens located on this continuum?
看待世界的一种方式是这样的。存在一个生命连续体。在一端，在极端的一端，你有植物、昆虫之类，我们大多数人对杀死或虐待它们感到毫无愧疚。在连续体的另一端，在另一个极端，你有狗、猫、海豹宝宝和人类，我们不能随心所欲地杀死、吃掉或残忍对待的动物。问题是，鸡在这个连续体上处于什么位置？
At different points during our conversation, Lloyd put chickens at different places on the continuum. Sometimes he said that he felt their pain. He empathized with their pain. Sometimes he went on these long tirades about how stupid chickens are.
在我们谈话的不同点上，劳埃德把鸡放在了连续体上的不同位置。有时他说他能感受到它们的痛苦。他同情它们的痛苦。有时他会对鸡有多蠢进行长篇大论。
The thing about chickens is they like eating eggs, but they don't know that the things they're laying are eggs. You get the occasional chicken that will eat eggs from the areas where they lay them, but by and large, that's not that common. But if you take an egg and throw it on the floor, all the chickens will run over and eat it.
关于鸡的一点是，它们喜欢吃蛋，但它们不知道它们下的是蛋。你偶尔会碰到一只鸡，它会吃掉它们下蛋区域的蛋，但总的来说，这并不常见。但如果你拿一个蛋扔在地板上，所有的鸡都会跑过来吃掉它。
That's horrifying.
那太可怕了。
I'm feeling some anguish about how I treated some of these chickens, chickens that are long gone, chickens that were only with me for a year.
我对自己曾经如何对待其中的一些鸡感到有些痛苦，那些早已离去的鸡，那些只和我相处了一年的鸡。
Chickens that didn't have names.
那些没有名字的鸡。
Chickens that individually meant nothing to me. You're going to make me out to be repentant.
那些对我来说毫无个体意义的鸡。你这是要让我看起来很忏悔。
No I'm not. I'm just going to follow the interview where it goes. Well, you sound weirdly repentant.
不，我不是。我只是要跟随采访的内容。嗯，你听起来奇怪地忏悔。
It's the weirdest thing, thinking about those poor, dumb chickens.
想到那些可怜、愚蠢的鸡，真是最奇怪的事。
Of course, the ultimate test of where you place a living thing on the life continuum is whether or not you're willing to put whatever it is into your mouth and eat it.
当然，你将一个活物放在生命连续体何处的终极测试，是你是否愿意把那个东西放进嘴里吃掉。
I still eat chicken.
我还是吃鸡。
Lloyd Natoff designs and builds custom furniture for a living here in Chicago. Coming up, the Trojan goose, chicken portraiture and other stories about birds that say more about us than they do about the birds in our annual Poultry Slam. In a minute from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
劳埃德·纳托夫在芝加哥以设计和建造定制家具为生。接下来，特洛伊鹅、鸡的肖像画以及其他关于鸟类的故事，在我们的年度“家禽狂欢”中，这些鸟类比它们本身说明了更多关于我们的东西。稍后从国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on the theme. Today's program, during the weeks between Thanksgiving Christmas, the weeks of greatest poultry consumption in America, it is our annual Poultry Slam. Stories of chicken, turkeys, ducks, fowl of all kind, and how we turn them into mirrors of ourselves. We have arrived at Act Three of our program, Duck Warrior.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，在感恩节和圣诞节之间，美国人消费家禽最多的几周，是我们年度的“家禽狂欢”。关于鸡、火鸡、鸭子、各种家禽的故事，以及我们如何把它们变成我们自己的镜子。我们已经到了节目的第三幕，“鸭子战士”。
If how we raise chickens says a lot about ourselves, how we hunt them says just as much. We have this account of one family's mortal reckoning with birds, and with their own souls, from Michael Lewis.
如果我们饲养鸡的方式说明了很多关于我们自己的事，那么我们猎杀它们的方式也说明了同样多的事。我们有迈克尔·刘易斯关于一个家庭与鸟类以及与他们自己灵魂的生死较量的记录。
Every other year or so during Christmas vacation, I stuff myself into the camouflage suit of goose down and rubber and strike out with my father and a few of his friends into the swamps of southwestern Louisiana. For nearly 20 years now, I have followed him into the darkness, as blindly as Isaac followed Abraham, to stalk waterfowl through a gauntlet of pricker bushes, sawgrass, quick mud, snakes, mosquitoes, wild dogs, alligators and even the odd hostile cow.
每隔一年左右的圣诞假期，我就会把自己塞进鹅绒和橡胶的迷彩服里，和父亲以及他的一些朋友一起闯入路易斯安那州西南部的沼泽地。近20年来，我像以撒跟随亚伯拉罕一样盲目地跟随他走进黑暗，穿过荆棘丛、锯齿草、快泥、蛇、蚊子、野狗、短吻鳄，甚至是偶尔出现的一头敌对的牛，去跟踪水禽。
Because everything in the Louisiana swamp seems slightly unhinged and unpredictable, it seems almost natural there that, for example, the common cow would charge an armed man as fiercely as the rabbit charged Jimmy Carter. And force him to choose between humiliating death and the indignity of shooting a cow in self-defense.
因为路易斯安那州沼泽里的一切似乎都稍微有点精神错乱且不可预测，所以那里的母牛像兔子攻击吉米·卡特一样猛烈地冲向一个武装人员，这似乎很自然。并迫使他不得不在屈辱的死亡和为了自卫射杀一头牛的耻辱之间做出选择。
But of all the life in the swamp, nothing is quite so transformed by the place as the otherwise intelligent human being in pursuit of the elusive waterfowl. I suppose I should say that I see nothing immoral in this, though I often have sensed mild disapproval in people who do not hunt of people who do. As they slice deeply into the flesh of what was once an adorable little lamb, and then tear it greedily with their back teeth, these people will say something like, "How can you kill a cute little duck?" The honest answer is, sadly, that I don't.
但在沼泽里的所有生命中，没有比正在追逐难以捉摸的水禽的聪明人类被改变得更彻底的了。我想我应该说，我觉得这没有什么不道德的，尽管我经常感觉到那些不狩猎的人对狩猎的人表现出轻微的反对。当他们深深地切开曾经是一只可爱小羊羔的肉，然后用后槽牙贪婪地撕扯时，这些人会说类似的话：“你怎么能杀死一只可爱的小鸭子？”诚实的答案是，可悲的是，我没有。
Looking back on it now, I believe we began two decades ago with the ambition of one day becoming purists. The hunting purist is able to make himself think and feel like a duck or a goose. He enters the swap at 5:00 in the morning with 10 shotgun shells and returns three hours later with his legal limit of three ducks and seven geese. He can carve wooden ducks so similar to live ducks that even ducks don't notice the difference. And make noises with his mouth that sound so much like a female duck on the make that male ducks flock to him like sailors to a brothel.
回首往事，我相信我们在二十年前开始时，有着有一天成为纯粹主义者的雄心。狩猎纯粹主义者能够让自己像鸭子或鹅一样思考和感受。他早上5点带着10发散弹枪弹进入沼泽，三小时后带着3只鸭子和7只鹅的法定狩猎量回来。他能雕刻出与活鸭如此相似的木鸭，以至于鸭子都注意不到区别。并且能用嘴发出听起来非常像处于发情期的雌鸭的声音，以至于雄鸭像水手涌向妓院一样涌向他。
I confess there was a time when this seemed important to us, and some of my earliest memories are of my father sitting on our back porch imitating for hours a tape recording of duck mating calls. But over the years, it became clear that no matter how long we practiced this inter-species flirtation, we would never score. As this truth dawned, we began busily to fill the gap between our ambitions and our talents with the latest in hunting technology.
我承认曾经有一段时间这对我来说很重要，我最早的一些记忆是我父亲坐在后廊上花几个小时模仿录音带上的鸭子交配叫声。但多年来，很明显，无论我们练习这种跨物种调情多久，我们都不会得分。随着真相大白，我们开始忙碌地用最新的狩猎技术填补我们雄心和天赋之间的空白。
Unable to speak with the birds, we communicated instead with each other. We carried Walkie Talkies so that we might fan out in the swamp and relay to each other various duck data. We carried flares to better see each other in the dark. And then there were the more adventurous techniques. In the late 1970's, it was widely believed, for example, that to a goose flying high in the sky, a balled up newspaper resembled a sitting goose. For several years, we spread The Wall Street Journal across the Louisiana wetlands, fully believing that a goose would spot the stock quotes, or perhaps an opera review, and dive down for a closer look.
无法与鸟类交谈，我们转而进行互相交流。我们带着对讲机，这样我们就可以在沼泽里散开并互相传递各种鸭子数据。我们带着照明弹以便在黑暗中更好地看见对方。然后还有更冒险的技术。例如，在20世纪70年代末，人们普遍认为，对于飞在高空中的鹅来说，揉成一团的报纸看起来像是一只坐着的鹅。有几年，我们把《华尔街日报》铺在路易斯安那州的湿地上，完全相信鹅会发现股票行情，或者可能是一篇歌剧评论，然后俯冲下来一探究竟。
After a while, when we had nothing to show for this but a soggy mess, we moved on from newspapers to life-sized, plastic replicas of geese. When these also failed, another theory soon made the rounds. Geese lacked size perception. A goose the size of the World Trade Center looked, to a goose, like just another goose. And so, for the next several years, our plastic replicas of the geese swelled to three or four times the size of a live goose. The added size did not help as far as I could see.
过了一会儿，当我们除了湿漉漉的一团糟之外一无所获时，我们从报纸换成了真人大小的塑料鹅复制品。当这些也失败后，另一个理论很快流传开来。鹅缺乏大小感知。一只世界贸易中心那么大的鹅，在鹅看来，就像另一只鹅。所以，在接下来的几年里，我们的塑料鹅复制品膨胀到了活鹅的三到四倍大小。据我所见，增加的大小并没有什么帮助。
Only now do I understand that our many beliefs about geese would lead us inevitably to embrace the Trojan goose. The Trojan goose was advertised by one of the many companies that specialize in supplying frustrated hunters with high technology. It was, as it sounds, a hollowed out replica of a goose, complete with eye holes and large enough for two hunters to stand comfortably inside of it. It was meant to be erected in the middle of a goose feeding ground. One wing disguised a kind of trap door.
直到现在我才明白，我们关于鹅的许多信念注定会引导我们拥抱“特洛伊鹅”。特洛伊鹅是由众多专门为受挫的猎人提供高科技服务的公司之一所推销的。正如听起来那样，它是一个空心的鹅复制品，配有观察孔，大到足以让两名猎人舒服地站在里面。它原本打算竖立在鹅的觅食地中间。一只翅膀伪装了一种陷阱门。
The idea was that once the geese gathered around their gargantuan cousin, the hunters might throw open the trap door, storm out into their unsuspecting midst and visit death and destruction upon many wild beasts. Just moments before we purchased the Trojan goose, however, something happened. I'm not sure what, perhaps some combination of self-revulsion and self-examination. At heart, we realized, we were not technologists. We were spiritualists.
这个想法是，一旦鹅聚集在它们庞大的表亲周围，猎人们就可以猛地打开陷阱门，冲进它们毫无防备的中间，对许多野生动物施以死亡和毁灭。然而，就在我们购买特洛伊鹅的前一刻，发生了某些事。我不确定是什么，也许是自我厌恶和自我反省的某种结合。在内心深处，我们意识到，我们不是技术专家。我们是唯灵论者。
The spiritualist is the hunter who has learned to shift the emphasis of the hunting away from the killing. He knows he can shiver ducklessly for hours behind a clump of marsh grass, expertly imitating a pintail's whistle or a mallard drake's quack with a textbook, perfect semicircle of decoys at his front and the wind and the sunrise at his back. Then, the moment he deserts his position to answer a call of nature, the ducks will descend like Japanese zeros. Looking like a cross between a flasher and an advertisement for the National Rifle Association, he will lurch for his gun and go down with a small splash as the ducks exit safely, chuckling lightly.
唯灵论者是那种已经学会将狩猎重心从杀戮中移开的猎人。他知道他可以在草丛后因为没有鸭子而发抖几个小时，专家级地模仿针尾鸭的哨声或绿头鸭的嘎嘎声，并在身前放置一个完美的半圆形诱饵，身后是风和日出。然后，当他离开岗位去回答自然的呼唤的那一刻，鸭子会像日本零式战斗机一样俯冲下来。看起来像是暴露狂和全国步枪协会广告的结合体，他会踉踉跄跄地去拿枪，随着鸭子安全撤离并发出轻快的笑声，他会带着小小的水花掉进水里。
We have come very far in these 20 years. A few weeks ago, my father set off one morning on foot through the swamp. He came through a clearing and walked into several acres of ducks and geese feeding on the ground. They continued to feed while he watched. It was the largest collection of potential victims ever to sit quietly within the range of a Lewis gun. He might have murdered a flock had he been that sort of hunter. Instead, he stood in awe and watched until they all flew away.
这20年来我们走得很远。几周前，我父亲早上徒步走进沼泽。他穿过一片空地，走进了几英亩在地面上觅食的鸭子和鹅中间。当他观察时，它们继续进食。那是刘易斯枪射程内坐过最庞大的一群潜在受害者。如果他是那种猎人，他本可以屠杀一群。相反，他敬畏地站着看着，直到它们全部飞走。
Michael Lewis is the author of Trail Fever and other books.
迈克尔·刘易斯是《Trail Fever》和其他书的作者。
Act Four, Trying to Respect a Chicken. Sure, it's one thing to take a fictional character like Chicken Little and make her a star. Try doing it with a real chicken, just try.
第四幕，“试图尊重那只鸡”。当然，把像“小鸡快跑”这样的虚构角色变成明星是一回事。尝试用一只真正的鸡来做这件事，试试看。
Well, these are photographs of chickens. The first one here is a Silver Laced Wyandotte. It's a black and white bird, essentially, but the tail feathers have a lot of iridescent green coloring.
嗯，这些是鸡的照片。第一个是一只银领维安多特鸡。它本质上是一只黑白相间的鸟，但尾羽有许多虹彩的绿色。
In a world where chickens get no respect, Tamara Staples treats them the way that humans treat those we revere the most. She takes their portraits, lovingly. Her shots are like fashion photographs, beautifully lit, color backdrops. They're beautiful.
在一个鸡得不到尊重的世界里，塔玛拉·斯台普斯像人类对待我们最崇敬的对象那样对待它们。她充满爱意地为它们拍摄肖像。她的作品就像时尚摄影，光影优美，色彩背景。它们很美。
So now, the first one looked regal, but now you've just turned to one where it almost looks like a clown. It looks comic.
所以现在，第一张看起来很威严，但现在你转到了一张看起来几乎像小丑的照片。它看起来很滑稽。
It's a Mottled Houdan, which I always call the Phyllis Diller chicken.
这是一只斑点胡丹鸡，我总是称之为“菲利斯·迪勒”鸡。
Oh my god, that chicken does look like Phyllis Diller.
天哪，那只鸡看起来确实像菲利斯·迪勒。
It does. It's the hat. It got this huge feathered hat thing and a strange body shape.
真的。是那顶帽子。它有那种巨大的羽毛帽子和奇怪的身体形状。
In a way, it's Tamra Staples is running an odd little cross-species science experiment, one that asks this question. What happens when you try to treat a chicken the way we treat humans, even if it's just for the length of a photo shoot? What happens, it turns out, is that you learn just where the thin line is that divides human beings from birds. All right, maybe it's not such a thin line, but it's definitely a line. And, like most city people, I had never thought about it, about where it lies, about what it might be, what it might consist of, until Tamara headed out to a farm.
从某种程度上讲，塔玛拉·斯台普斯正在进行一个奇怪的跨物种小科学实验，这个实验提出了一个问题。当你尝试以对待人类的方式对待一只鸡时，即使只是在拍摄期间，会发生什么？事实证明，你会学到区分人类和鸟类的细微界限在哪里。好吧，也许那条界线没那么细，但它绝对是一条界线。而且，像大多数城市人一样，我从来没想过它，想过它在哪里，它可能是什么，它可能由什么组成，直到塔玛拉前往一个农场。
[CHICKENS CROWING]
[鸡叫声]
I think that is the best one.
我认为那是最好的一张。
Yeah, we have to get him. We don't want him to get dirty or anything, do we? Or does it matter?
是的，我们必须抓住它。我们不想让它弄脏什么的，对吧？或者这有关系吗？
She runs loose every day.
它每天都散养。
Can we find her?
我们能找到它吗？
Yeah, we can fake her out.
可以，我们可以用计骗它。
We're going to wrangle him.
我们要去把它引过来。
We're at the Davidson's dairy farm, about an hour and a half northwest of Chicago. Family members present-- Paul, who's helping Tamara choose a bird photograph, his sister Laura, who's studying photography at a nearby university. Their grandfather George Cairns, a veteran breeder. Their father Dick, who seems the most skeptical of this whole project, but who patiently shows Tamara and her assistant Dennis the milking barn as a possible place to set up and shoot.
我们在戴维森奶牛场，芝加哥西北约一个半小时路程。出席的家庭成员有——保罗，正在帮助塔玛拉选择一张照片里的鸟；他的妹妹劳拉，正在附近一所大学学习摄影；他们的祖父乔治·凯恩斯，一位资深的饲养员；他们的父亲迪克，似乎对整个项目最怀疑，但他耐心地向塔玛拉和她的助手丹尼斯展示了挤奶牛棚，作为设置拍摄地点的可能场所。
What kind of an area are you looking for?
你在找什么样的区域？
Well, maybe it could be a little wider, don't you think? And if could be from here to there, and from that pole to that pole.
嗯，也许可以稍微宽一点，你不觉得吗？如果能从这儿到那儿，从那根柱子到那根柱子。
For what? I don't understand.
为了什么？我不明白。
Well, we are setting-- maybe this is a good time to pull out the portfolio. Do you want to grab it? It's a study of the birds, but it's an isolated study so people aren't necessarily associating it with the farm and something to eat.
嗯，我们正在设置——也许现在是拿出作品集的好时机。你想拿一下吗？这是对鸟类的研究，但它是孤立的研究，所以人们不一定会把它与农场和食物联系起来。
Tamara takes us all outside the barn so dust won't get on her photos and shows them her shots, name dropping the names of some big chicken people, people whose birds she's photographed, including Bob Wullf editor of The Poultry Press. Dick notices that a bird in one photo has crooked toes.
塔玛拉带我们所有人走出牛棚，以免灰尘弄到她的照片上，并向他们展示她的作品，提到了一些鸡界大佬的名字，也就是那些被她拍摄过鸟类的人，包括《家禽新闻》的编辑鲍勃·伍尔夫。迪克注意到一张照片里的鸟脚趾弯曲。
Probably on a a higher surface and he turned.
可能是因为站在更高的表面上，它扭到了。
What do you guys think of the pictures?
你们觉得这些照片怎么样？
Well, the pictures are nice and sharp. I mean there's nothing wrong with the pictures. If there's anything to find fault with, it's the birds. They aren't posing the way they should, some of them.
嗯，照片很清晰。我的意思是照片没什么问题。如果非要找出什么毛病的话，那是鸟的问题。它们没有按照应该的方式摆姿势，有些鸟。
The fact is, most city people usually go nuts when they see Tamara's pictures. A lot of chicken breeders don't like them. And to understand why, to fully comprehend this little culture clash here in America, we have to leave the barnyard and flash back to something happened back at Tamara's apartment in the city.
事实是，大多数城市人在看到塔玛拉的照片时通常会发疯。很多鸡的饲养员不喜欢它们。要理解原因，要完全理解美国这种小小的文化冲突，我们必须离开谷仓，回溯到塔玛拉在城市的公寓里发生的事情。
Tamara showed me this old, red book from the turn of the century, this book with the seal of the American Poultry Association in gold on the front. And then, right there in gold letters--
塔玛拉向我展示了这本世纪之交的老红色书，这本书的封面上印有美国家禽协会的金印。然后，就在那儿，用金字写着——
Standard of perfection. The standard of perfection is really the Bible of poultry standards. What birds are--
“完美标准”。《完美标准》确实是家禽标准的圣经。关于什么样的鸟是——
Tamara flipped past the engravings and illustrations of chickens of all types and breeds. These were show chickens, standing the way that chickens stand in competitions. Then Tamara pulled out one of her own photos to compare, to show me how her poses do not meet the standard in the book.
塔玛拉翻过各种类型和品种的鸡的雕版和插图。这些是展示鸡，以比赛中鸡站立的方式站立。然后塔玛拉拿出她自己的一张照片进行比较，向我展示她的摆拍姿势为何不符合书中的标准。
The tail needs to be higher. Her feet are not erect standing. Chest isn't out. Head needs to be up more. And it shows. I mean you can see the shape of the chicken much better in the standard of perfection pose.
尾巴需要更高。她的脚没有直立站立。胸部没有挺出来。头需要抬高一点。而且这表现出来了。我的意思是，在《完美标准》的姿势中，你可以看得更清楚鸡的形状。
See to me, what's so interesting though is that the standard of perfection doesn't include a personality.
对我来说，非常有趣的是，《完美标准》不包括个性。
Right, because it's not about personality. It's about breeding.
对，因为它不是关于个性。它是关于繁育。
So is that a pose that the owners would want to own a photo of?
那么那是饲养者想要收藏照片的姿势吗？
They are very particular about-- they want to see their bird in the standard of perfection pose, definitely. Because that's what they've been taught from 4H, when they were kids, to do.
他们非常讲究——他们绝对想看到他们的鸟以《完美标准》的姿势呈现。因为那是他们从小在4H俱乐部学到的。
That's for them. For herself, for her city customers, she chooses the others. OK, back to the barnyard. Tamara and the Davidsons decide to set up the photo session in a room that's usually used to store feed for the cows. It takes about 45 minutes to set this up. That 45 minutes includes dismantling and moving a wall of hay that is probably 10 feet high and 15 feet long. This takes five people. Then, in comes the power and the fancy lights and the cloth backdrop that gets hung from the steel pole. The backdrop is ironed first with an iron and ironing board brought from the city just for that purpose.
那是他们的。对于她自己，对于她的城市客户，她选择了其他的。好的，回到谷仓。塔玛拉和戴维森一家决定在一个通常用来储存牛饲料的房间里进行拍摄。设置这个场景花费了大约45分钟。那45分钟包括拆除和移动一面可能有10英尺高、15英尺长的干草墙。这需要五个人。然后，电力、华丽的灯光和从钢柱上挂下来的布背景进场了。背景是先用从城市特意带来的熨斗和熨衣板熨平的。
11.5, 11, and an 8.5.
11.5，11，还有8.5。
Yeah, 11.5. Your test is going to be at 11.5, 11 and 8.5. You'll shoot your film at 11.
是的，11.5。你的测试应该在11.5，11和8.5。你的胶卷在11档拍摄。
It was cold, well below freezing, so cold that the Polaroid film that Tamara uses for lighting tests would not fully develop.
天气很冷，远低于冰点，以至于塔玛拉用于照明测试的宝丽来胶片无法完全显影。
You ready for bird?
准备好鸟了吗？
We're close. I just want to commune with the bird. I just want to make you pretty. Look how sweet, aren't you? You know what? I'm going to photograph you. My name is Tamara. I'll you photographer for today.
快了。我只想和这只鸟交流一下。我只想让你变得漂亮。看，多甜美，不是吗？你知道吗？我要给你拍照。我叫塔玛拉。我是你今天的摄影师。
Our first bird is a White Cornish, a show bird who belongs to George. This show bird is used to being picked up and handled. Part of preparing chicken for shows involves handling them a lot so they'll be calm with the judges.
我们的第一只鸟是一只白科尼什鸡，属于乔治的展示鸟。这只展示鸟习惯于被抱起和处理。为表演准备鸡的部分工作涉及大量处理它们，以便它们在裁判面前保持冷静。
If you could just nudge his head up a little bit, he's perfect. He's got his chest up. OK, now he's got his face in. OK, yeah, you know what we want. Great, George. He's got a feather on his back here.
如果你能把它的头稍微抬起来一点，它就完美了。它的胸部挺起来了。好的，现在它的脸进来了。好的，你知道我们想要什么。太棒了，乔治。它背上有根羽毛在这儿。
Tamara has the Cornish stand up on a stack of little red, antique books, kind of unsteady. Things go well for a while. She get a half dozen good shots of the bird, expressive shots, more personality than standard of perfection, George tells me. The bird's chest isn't high enough. Its body is not turned correctly to the camera. And then, the bird stops cooperating. He gets tired. Paul has a suggestion.
塔玛拉让科尼什鸡站在一叠红色的小古董书上，有点不稳。事情顺利了一会儿。她拍了半打不错的照片，充满表现力的照片，比《完美标准》有更多个性，乔治告诉我。这只鸟的胸部不够高。它的身体没有转向摄像机。然后，这只鸟停止了配合。它累了。保罗有个建议。
Bring in a pullet?
带一只小母鸡来？
You know what? You know that works.
你知道吗？你知道那招管用。
Maybe you should explain what that is. What does that mean to bring in a pullet?
也许你应该解释一下那是什么。带一只小母鸡来是什么意思？
Thinks maybe a female will perk him up.
觉得也许雌性能让它兴奋起来。
Laura grabs a hen and waves it at the flaccid cock. The cock does not rise. I can say that on the radio, right?
劳拉抓了一只母鸡，在松弛的公鸡面前挥舞。那只公鸡没有站起来。我在电台上可以这么说，对吧？
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] probably would have better to get the one from the other pen that he's not used to.
[听不清] 可能最好是从它不习惯的另一个笼子里拿那只。
Fresh blood. Bring him around a little bit so his-- [INTERPOSING VOICES]
新鲜血液。把它转过来一点，让它的—— [交叉声音]
For real, the rooster will show off more for a hen that it doesn't know?
真的，公鸡会在它不认识的母鸡面前展示得更多？
Yes. If you put a new hen in with him or pen him with a group of new hens, he will really show off.
是的。如果你放一只新母鸡进去或者把它和一群新母鸡关在一起，它真的会炫耀。
They try this and that, nothing with much success. And finally, with one shot left, Paul suggests putting a hen into the picture with the rooster.
他们尝试了这个和那个，没什么太大成功。最后，剩下最后一张照片时，保罗建议把一只母鸡放进那张公鸡的照片里。
Get the girl to-- she looks like her feet are so far apart. She's really struggling to stand.
让女孩……她看起来脚分得太开了。她真的很努力地在站着。
That's the way they stand though.
但它们就是那样站的。
That's all right. Oh, did you see that? All right. we got it.
没关系。哦，你看到了吗？好的。我们拍到了。
Why? What did she just do? Describe.
为什么？她刚才做了什么？描述一下。
She looked up at him very sweetly, like that, with her head cocked. The male bird was posing, and she was posing also but had a personality of just being like the sweet, doting mother.
她很甜美地抬头看着它，像那样，歪着头。雄鸟在摆姿势，她也在摆姿势，但表现出一种就像甜美、溺爱母亲般的个性。
But not standard of perfection?
但不是《完美标准》？
But not standard of perfection. So we're done with this background and--
但不是《完美标准》。所以这个背景我们拍完了，然后——
Not standard of perfection. Even these perfectly bred Cornishes could not achieve standard of perfection today. And even in this goofy, un-birdlike situation, an hour of watching them makes clear just how hard it is ever to get birds to hit the standard.
不是《完美标准》。即使是这些精心培育的科尼什鸡今天也无法达到《完美标准》。即使在这种笨拙的、非鸟类的处境下，看着它们一个小时就能清楚地知道让鸟类达到标准有多么困难。
Which is to say, not only do we completely dominate every aspect of the lives of chickens, their births, their feed, their eggs, their slaughter. Not only have we bred them to human specifications to meet human needs, but we've created a standard of what it means to be chicken that most chickens can never meet. That's what the standard means. We judge them as chickens, and we find them lacking. If they had the brains to understand this, they would be right to feel indignant.
也就是说，我们不仅完全支配了鸡生活的方方面面——它们的出生、饲料、鸡蛋、宰杀。我们不仅按照人类的需求、按人类的规格培育了它们，而且我们还创造了一个关于“身为鸡”意味着什么的判断标准，大多数鸡永远无法达到。这就是标准的含义。我们作为鸡来评判它们，发现它们不合格。如果它们有脑子能理解这一点，它们感到愤慨是正确的。
But of course, this is a city person's perspective. And that means it is completely wrongheaded from the point of view of anybody who actually raises birds. Standing in the cold feed room, I had a long, long talk with George about this. George is 80 years old. He's been raising birds since, I guess, the Calvin Coolidge administration. And he says the whole fun of raising birds is raising them to the standard.
但当然，这是城市人的视角。这意味着从任何真正饲养鸟类的人的角度来看，这是完全错误的。站在寒冷的饲料室里，我和乔治就此进行了很长很长的谈话。乔治80岁了。我猜他从卡尔文·柯立芝执政时期就开始养鸟了。他说养鸟的全部乐趣在于把它们培养成符合标准的样子。
Well, like for instance, if your birds lack bone. OK, you go out and buy a bird as nearly like them as you can with better bone. But when you mate them together, you might get long-legged birds or too short. I mean you don't get what you want just by mating. It takes four, five years to gradually get it up. And by that time, they're inbred and you need new ones.
嗯，比如，如果你的鸟缺乏骨架。好的，你出去买一只和你现有的尽可能接近但骨架更好的鸟。但当你把它们交配在一起时，你可能会得到长腿的鸟或者太短的。我的意思是，你不能只通过交配得到你想要的。需要四五年时间慢慢把它提上来。到那时，它们已经近亲繁殖了，你需要新的。
George tells me that when he's breeding a new batch of birds, he'll hatch 65 of them, and only one or two will be anywhere near the standard of perfection. That's how hard it is.
乔治告诉我，当他繁育新一批鸟时，他会孵化65只，只有一两只会接近《完美标准》。这太难了。
Do you get frustrated with the standard of perfection sometimes?
你有时会对《完美标准》感到沮丧吗？
No, we get frustrated with the judges because every judge has his own idea what the standard should be.
不，我们是对裁判感到沮丧，因为每个裁判对自己认为标准应该是什么样都有自己的想法。
But I thought that's the whole point of a standard is that the judge doesn't--
但我以为标准的意义就在于裁判不应该——
That is, but one judge will want it this way, and another another. Today, if you bred your birds to the standard of protection, weight and everything, and took them to the show, you probably wouldn't get anywhere. You have to breed to the fads.
确实，但一个裁判会想要这样，另一个想要那样。今天，如果你按照完美标准，体重和一切去繁育你的鸟，然后带它们去参赛，你可能一事无成。你必须为了潮流而繁育。
That's right, the fads, like Cornishes these days are supposed to have shorter legs than the real standard of perfection. Vertical tail feathers are out and all sorts of breeds that really should have them. In the country, among the chicken breeders, they think about a lot of things you never get to in the city.
没错，潮流，比如现在的科尼什鸡被要求有比真正《完美标准》更短的腿。垂直尾羽被淘汰了，而实际上很多品种应该有。在乡村，在鸡的饲养者中，他们思考很多你在城市里永远不会想到的东西。
And when you're raising these birds, with any of these birds, do you have a close relationship with a bird the way somebody would have with a pet?
当你养这些鸟时，无论哪种，你有像别人对待宠物那样与鸟有密切的关系吗？
I don't have time. I have too many things to do. A few years ago, I almost died of cancer. And the good Lord told me how to cure myself, and so I've been working with that a lot the last three years. I've helped people and put it it papers. Now, it's getting all over the United States.
我没时间。我有太多事情要做。几年前，我差点死于癌症。仁慈的上帝告诉了我如何治愈自己，所以过去三年我在这方面做了很多工作。我帮助过人们，并且登在了报纸上。现在，它传遍了美国各地。
What did you do?
你做了什么？
You use the root of a dandelion. Simple as can be, but there's something in that that builds up your blood and your immune system.
你用蒲公英的根。简单得不能再简单，但其中有些东西能增强你的血液和免疫系统。
Wait a a senior. You're saying that you were diagnosed with cancer, and this is the only treatment you had, and it cured you?
等等，老先生。你是说你被诊断出患有癌症，而这是你唯一的治疗方法，而且它治愈了你？
Yeah, and I've given it to to other people when the medical world has told them that there's nothing more they can do. And they've gotten well too, but not all of them. If they're too far gone, it won't help them.
是的，当医学界告诉他们无能为力时，我把它给了其他人。他们也康复了，但不是全部。如果他们病得太重，它就帮不了他们。
And you make it into tea or something like that?
你把它做成茶之类的吗？
We just put it in a little water, a little milk, Kool-Aid. You can put it on a sandwich, anything that isn't hot.
我们只是把它放在一点水里，一点牛奶，酷爱（Kool-Aid）。你可以把它放在三明治上，任何不烫的东西。
George gives me a pamphlet that he's written up. No doctor has actually checked him out to prove the cancer is gone from his body. He's actually got no hard, scientific proof that this really works, but he says God told him that this is the way he should be spending his time. And it has cut into his bird breeding a bit.
乔治给了我一份他写的小册子。没有医生真正检查过他来证明癌症已从他的身体中消失。他实际上没有任何确凿的科学证据证明这真的有效，但他说是上帝告诉他这是他应该花时间做的事。这在一定程度上影响了他的养鸟工作。
George leaves, off on other business. Tamara has finished hanging and lighting the next backdrop. And the rest of us begin with the second bird, a bird called a Brahma with elaborately patterned brown and white feather.
乔治离开了，去忙其他事情了。塔玛拉完成了挂起和布置下一个背景。我们其他人开始处理第二只鸟，一种被称为婆罗门鸡的鸟，有着精心设计的棕色和白色羽毛图案。
She is a big. This is a chicken the size of a dog.
她很大。这是一只像狗一样大的鸡。
Not that big. A small dog.
没那么大。一只小狗。
Our second bird demonstrates the great distance between bird instinct and intelligence and the demands of modern fashion photography, which is to say, of civilization. Called upon to do human tasks, even rather passive ones, a bird remains a bird. Paul carries the huge hen onto the fragile little set Tamara has built.
我们的第二只鸟展示了鸟类的直觉和智力与现代时尚摄影——也就是文明——的要求之间的巨大鸿沟。被要求执行人类的任务，即使是相当被动的任务，鸟仍然是鸟。保罗把这只巨大的母鸡抬到塔玛拉建造的脆弱的小场景上。
She's a beauty? What are you eating there buddy? Oh, it slapped me.
她是个美人吗？你在吃什么，伙计？哦，它打了我的脸。
"I'm scared of this one," she says quietly as she adjusts her camera. The chicken is so big, nine pounds, the size of a small consumer turkey, that she has to pull the camera back. Then there are the props. She's trying an experiment, putting a little toy horse in the picture with the chicken, a tiny wagon. This does not seem to help things. The Davidsons are looking at her skeptically. Paul asks pointedly if she's ever shot a bird this big.
“我害怕这个，”她一边调整相机一边轻声说。这只鸡太大了，九磅，像一只小型的消费级火鸡，以至于她不得不把相机向后拉。然后还有道具。她正在尝试一个实验，把一只小玩具马和一辆小马车放在那只鸡的照片里。这似乎没什么帮助。戴维森一家怀疑地看着她。保罗尖锐地问她是否拍过这么大的鸟。
We have to figure out where the-- [CHICKEN SOUNDS]
我们必须弄清楚哪里—— [鸡叫声]
That's the sound of a frightened chicken.
那是受惊的鸡的声音。
Imagine this please from the point of view of the chicken. OK, you're surrounded by powerful creatures five times your height. They crowd in at you. They leer at you. You are standing on a surface, Tamara's set, where it is impossible to get decent footing. There is a three foot tall strobe light, a strobe light twice your height, just a wing's length away from your beaky little face.
请从鸡的角度想象一下。好吧，你被一群身高是你五倍的强大生物包围了。他们围着你。他们斜眼看你。你正站在一个表面上——塔玛拉的布景——那里不可能站稳。有一个三英尺高的闪光灯，一个是你身高两倍的闪光灯，离你尖尖的小脸只有一翼之遥。
She just--
它刚才——
She needs a few minutes just to relax. Hello bird, are you going to slap me in the face again?
她需要几分钟才能放松。你好，鸟，你又要打我的脸吗？
She tends to jump right in your face.
她倾向于直接跳到你的脸上。
You know why you're here? Let's talk. We need you to be beautiful. Here's your moment. OK? There are more where you came from, buddy. You better act up here.
你知道你为什么在这儿吗？我们谈谈。我们需要你变得漂亮。这是你的时刻。好吗？伙计，你还有很多同伴。你最好表现好点。
This combination of coddling and threats might motivate and aspiring supermodel or an eager puppy, but this, after all, is a chicken. Forget standard of perfection, this chicken does not even stand up straight. It sags. It slouches. Laura tries to lure it up with a handful of corn.
这种溺爱和威胁的结合可能会激励有抱负的超模或急切的小狗，但毕竟，这是一只鸡。别提什么《完美标准》了，这只鸡甚至站不直。它下垂。它无精打采。劳拉试图用一把玉米引诱它站起来。
Is she standing?
她站着吗？
We put corn where she's trying to get it, but she has to stand up high for it.
我们把玉米放在她试图去拿的地方，但她必须站高一点才行。
Is that where you want her to stand?
那是你想让她站的地方吗？
We'd like her to stand up.
我们希望她站起来。
Pretty much.
差不多。
Somewhere during this ordeal, a funny thing happens. All the Davidsons, who all started off skeptical, they are completely engaged. Dick suggests a pose that is pure art concept, a pose that could not be further from standard of perfection. Laura lures the bird with corn. Paul smooths feathers. Dick and Ella and Gary, two other relatives-- the had all been standing back at the edges of the feed room. Now, they all lean in right next to Tamara. And when the bird quivers or moves a wing, three people jump in to fix it back up.
在这个磨难的过程中，发生了一件有趣的事。所有的戴维森一家，他们一开始都很怀疑，现在完全投入进去了。迪克提出了一个纯艺术概念的姿势，一个离《完美标准》再远不过的姿势。劳拉用玉米诱惑这只鸟。保罗抚平羽毛。迪克、埃拉和加里，其他两名亲戚——他们之前都站在饲料室的边缘。现在，他们都 lean 进了塔玛拉身边。当这只鸟颤抖或移动翅膀时，三个人跳进去把它扶正。
There are some feathers on the breast a little bit fluffy. She's not real clean down there. That looks good. She's a little farther. You guys are a great team. I'm going to hire you to come with me. Oops. I've got a hand in there. That's right. Move the hand. Move the hand. Move the hand. OK great.
胸部有一些羽毛有点蓬松。她下面不是很干净。看起来不错。她再远一点。你们是一个很棒的团队。我要雇你们跟我一起去。哎呀。我有只手在里面。没错。移开手。移开手。移开手。好的，太棒了。
It wasn't until this point that I realized that I came into this expecting the bird to be more-- well, more human, partly, I think, because I had never really thought about this one way or the other. But partly because Tamara's photos make chickens seem so thoughtful.
直到这一刻我才意识到，我来这里时期望这只鸟更——嗯，部分更像人，我想，因为我从来没有以某种方式思考过这个问题。但部分是因为塔玛拉的照片让鸡看起来如此深思熟虑。
Over here. Look at the camera.
在这儿。看摄像机。
Now she's completely out of frame.
现在她完全出框了。
Those photos are a lie.
那些照片是谎言。
[COAXING CHICKEN] Hello. Hey. She's kneeling right now. She's not standing as well as she could.
[诱哄鸡] 你好。嘿。她现在跪着呢。她站得不如她能站得那么好。
As the day continues and Tamara shoots other birds, it becomes clear. The glimpse of personality that she's able to capture on film, these are just momentary. These are fleeting. A bird turns its head for an instant at a certain angle, or a bird squints its eyes at the camera. And for a moment, through the camera lens, to a human, it looks like recognizable personality, emotion. But really, it's just a chicken.
随着一天的继续，塔玛拉拍摄了其他鸟类，情况变得清晰起来。她能在胶片上捕捉到的那一丝个性，这些只是暂时的。这些是转瞬即逝的。一只鸟在某个角度转了头，或者一只鸟对着镜头眯起眼睛。片刻之间，通过镜头，对人类来说，看起来像可识别的个性和情绪。但实际上，它只是一只鸡。
And watching, I think I begin to understand why the people who breed birds have no interest in photos that show chickens' true personalities. It's because that in their true personalities, chickens are kind of a pain in the ass.
看着这一切，我想我开始明白为什么那些繁育鸟类的人对展示鸡真实个性的照片没有兴趣了。这是因为在它们的真实个性中，鸡有点令人讨厌。
I think you're going to have a one-shot opportunity here. It's going to be when I let go. [CHICKEN NOISES] Jeez, I didn't even let go. I just started to let up, and he yanked it right out of my hand.
我觉得你在这里会有一个单次拍摄的机会。那将是在我放手的时候。[鸡叫声] 天哪，我还没放手呢。我只是开始放松，它就立刻从我手中拽走了。
Fact is, you try to give chickens respect. You can try to treat them with dignity and photograph them the way you'd photograph anything or anyone that's serious. But the chickens will not care. You can make them look dignified, but it is a brainless, bird-like dignity. And it is ephemeral?
事实是，你试图给鸡尊重。你可以尝试以尊严对待它们，并像拍摄任何严肃的事物或任何人一样拍摄它们。但鸡们不会在乎。你可以让它们看起来尊严，但那是一种无脑的、鸟类般的尊严。而且它是短暂的？
Do you feel like your relationship with chickens has changed because of this?
你觉得你和鸡的关系因为这个改变了吗？
No, not at all.
不，一点也没有。
How could that not be so?
怎么会这样呢？
I order the chicken when I'm at the show. I eat it right in front of the chickens.
我在演出时点了鸡肉。我在鸡面前直接吃它。
You eat chicken while you're standing there with a chicken?
你站在一只鸡旁边的时候吃鸡？
Yes. Is it wrong? I'm hungry.
是的。这不对吗？我饿了。
Well, no wonder they won't sit still.
嗯，难怪它们坐不住。
Yeah.
是啊。
[CHICKEN CRYING]
[鸡叫声]
We pack up our gear and move the massive wall of hay back into place. As we do this, chickens hop by, Brahmas, Ameraucana, mixed breeds. They seem utterly uninterested in us. They cluck at each other. There's feed to eat, hay to nestle in. They have better things to do with their time. And you know, there's nothing that makes you realize just how inhuman chickens are than spending a day trying to make them seem human.
我们打包设备，把那堵巨大的干草墙移回原位。当我们这样做时，鸡跳来跳去，婆罗门鸡、美国雅库塔鸡、杂交品种。它们似乎对我们完全不感兴趣。它们互相咯咯叫。有饲料要吃，有干草要窝进去。它们有更重要的事情要做。你知道，没有什么比花一天时间试图让鸡看起来像人更能让你意识到鸡是多么地不具人性了。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself, with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder, senior editor Paul Tough, contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margie Rockland and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Rachel Howard and Alex Blumberg. [ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
好了，我们今天的节目是由艾里克斯·斯皮格尔和我自己制作的，还有南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德，高级编辑保罗·塔夫，特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·洛克兰和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。制作协助来自雷切尔·霍华德和亚历克斯·布隆伯格。[致谢]
If you want to buy a tape of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago. That phone number, 312-832-3380. Again, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] . This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想购买本节目的录音，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ。电话号码是312-832-3380。再说一遍，312-832-3380。我们的电子邮箱地址是[email protected]。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who has found a perfect way to create a new radio host.
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚，他找到了一个创造新广播主持人的完美方式。
By sticking in small, painted Styrofoam ball onto a larger painted Styrofoam ball, poking in two map tacks for eyes--
通过把一个小小的、涂色的泡沫球粘在一个较大的涂色泡沫球上，戳上两个地图图钉作为眼睛——
Oh, you get the idea. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life. (HOST) ANNOUNCER: PRI, Public Radio International.
哦，你明白了。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。（主持人）播音员：PRI，国际公共广播电台。